mais non ça fait 150 milliards d'euros
pour l'union européenne la commission de
bruxelles a présenté son plan pour
répondre avec les u coronavirus il fait
la part belle aux subventions et
favorise les pays les plus touchés comme
l'italie et l'espagne
ce plan qui s'inspire en grande partie
des propositions françaises et
allemandes peut-il remporter l'adhésion
des plus réfractaires comme les pays-bas
ou l'autriche est il à la hauteur de la
récession historique qui nous attend on
voit cela avec vous jacques sapir
bonsoir jacques alors jacques bonsoir
c'est au niveau soir cette réponse de la
part de lieux qui a tardé temps et elle
au niveau des espérances et surtout des
besoins jacques
non absolument pas vous savez ici on
compare avec ce que font par exemple les
autres grands pays que ce soit la chine
où que ce soit les états unis et bien
les sommes qui sont envieuses sont très
faibles pour l'union européenne on est
actuellement autour de 3 % du pib alors
qu'on est entre 7 et 10% pour le plan de
relance seulement je parle pas des des
plans d'accompagnement de la crise née
pour le plan de relance mans on est
entre 7 et 10% du pib en chine et aux
états unis
alors oui on voit bien il ya un gros
problème maintenant le plan franco
allemand qui a été présentée le lundi 18
mai eh bien il propose 540 milliards ce
qui n'est pas rien évidemment puisque ça
viendrait s'ajouter aux 500 milliards
qui était déjà prévu mais ses 540
milliards eh bien il va s'agir
essentiellement de transferts
budgétaires puisque c'est de l'argent
que la commission de bruxelles
les vrais directement sur les marchés le
problème c'est évidemment cette
proposition a provoqué une crispation
chez les pays du nord ce qu'on appelle
les quatre frugaux la hollande la suède
le danemark vraiment et l'autriche et
que évidemment aidé on est parti dans
une dans un cycle de négociations on
peut même parler qu'on est parti pour un
nouveau cycle des faux semblant alors
jacques commençons par la proposition
franco allemand en fait avant ce plan de
relance de quoi s'agissait-il
alors faut savoir que cette cour
position c'était déjà un compromis la
france elle voulait un plan à 1500
milliards
l'allemagne a dit non mais elle a
accepté et ça c'est un point
effectivement très important elle a
accepté une forme de mutualisation des
dettes ce qu'elle avait complètement
refusé auparavant
alors ce plan de 500 milliards c'est de
l'argent qui viendra d'un endettement de
la commission européenne cet argent sera
redistribué aux pays qui en ont le plus
besoin
il sera redistribuée sous la forme de
subventions budgétaires ce qui équivaut
en faire quasiment des dons et puis bien
entendu au niveau du remboursement et
bien si jamais ces sommes soient
remboursés pas ce qui n'est pas du tout
sûr qu'elles soient remboursées bien si
jamais ces sommes doivent être un jour
rembourser elles le seront
essentiellement par des contributions au
budget ce qui veut dire que ce nouvel
endettement ne viendra pas s'inscrire
dans l'endettement déjà pris par ces
différents pays ça ne viendra pas sur le
fameux ratio dette sur piles qui est si
important pour certains pays on pense
notamment à l'italie
pourtant cette proposition jacques n'a
pas fait plaisir à tout le monde qu'on
que non
stéphanie haut que non et bien si vous
voulez donc les les quatre pays que j'ai
citées ce qu'on appelle les quatre
offres hugo ont immédiatement réagi au
delà il faut voir qu'il ya peut-être eu
une maladresse dans la manière dont ce
plan a été présenté parce que à faire un
plan entre la france et l'allemagne à ne
pas s'associer d'autres pays qui sont
des pays importants l'italie 3e matin
c'est là c'est la troisième économie de
l'union européenne l'espagne voire la
belgique
ou le portugal à ne pas associer ces
pays et on a donné l'impression que ben
voilà il y avait des pays qui étaient
plus égaux que d'autres pour reprendre
la phrase d'orwell et que la france et
l'allemagne voulait gouverner
l'union européenne alors au delà de
cette maladresse et bien il est clair
qu'il ya une opposition des pays dits
frugaux qui vraiment rejette la
dynamique globale de ce plan alors ces
pays dits frugaux ans comme vous dites
que propose-t-il alors c'est payé c'est
ça qu'il faut comprendre
d'un côté ils sont tout à fait d'accord
sur l'idée d'un fonds de relance qui
serait là lié aux circonstances tout à
fait exceptionnelles que nous vivons
c'est pas là dessus que se posent
l'essentiel du problème a eu ce qu'il
propose c'est que on est un plan qui
soit en fait fondés sur des prêts
ponctuelle aux pays qui en ont le plus
besoin
d'ailleurs c'est un point important il
ne mentionne aucune somme donc ça c'est
déjà un point qu'il faut relever et
c'est si vous laissez près ponctuelles
et bien il servirait évidemment à faire
des investissements dans les secteurs
qui en ont le plus besoin
évidemment l'économie verte la recherche
l'innovation mais il serait soumis à
l'engagement ferme pris par les pays qui
contracteraient évidemment un cdh est
donc cet engagement ferme à mettre en
oeuvre des réformes et à rester de
manière absolument strict dans les clous
de l'orthodoxie budgétaire et en quoi
jackass différent de la proposition
franco allemande alors alors une
première différence évidente un hymne et
plus du tout question de dette
mutualisée et là on voit très bien c'est
une rupture avec ce que veulent ou ce
que voudrait paris et berlin
et puis il ya un autre problème c'est
que si vous voulez ce plan eh bien il
fait référence aux grands principes
fondamentaux de l'union européenne et
ses principes fondamentaux ce sont
exactement les mêmes que ceux qui sous
tendent le fameux mécanisme si vous
voulez le mécanisme européen de
stabilité le ms
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire pour les pays qui contracteraient
des dettes dans ce cadre eh bien ça veut
dire se mettre sous la coupe de la
troïka se mettre dans la même situation
qu on était le portugal la grèce voire
l'espagne
de plus et c'est un point important les
quatre frugaux ne veulent pas que ce
plan de relance soit d'une certaine
manière pour l'éternité
ils demandent que la période soit
réduite à deux ans et ils demandent
surtout qu'il y ait une évaluation du
risque financier que ceux ci ferait
prendre à la commission alors restons
pour les desiderata non malheureusement
non ces pays ont même d'autres exigences
alors ils ont des exigences très nette
en ce qui concerne le budget européen
vous savez qu'on va devoir rediscuter du
budget européen sur la période 2021 et
2027 d'ailleurs à cause de la crise que
nous vivons actuellement est là encore
il demande à ce que ce soit des règles
d'austérité et des règles de frugalité
qui prévalent
il considère qu'il est dangereux que les
pays de l'union européenne
je dirais s'habitue à des budgets trop
important et pour en revenir à jacques
au plan de la relance de la commission
comment compellent le financer alors
c'est un point intéressant la commission
européenne a fait mercredi à dernier a
fait des propositions qui d'ailleurs
s'inspire assez largement des
propositions qui avaient été faites par
la france et l'allemagne
là encore il s'agirait d'un emprunt que
prendrait directement la commission
alors le point qui est un petit peu
important le point qui tranche
peut-être dans cette pro pendant cette
proposition de la commission par rapport
à la proposition franco allemand sait
que l'on devra les plus importantes
grosso modo 750 milliards mais elle est
divisée en deux il ya d'une part 500
milliards qui seraient en réalité des
fonds budgétaires et là on retrouve la
mécanique qui était celle du plan franco
allemand et puis il ya 250 milliards qui
seraient plutôt des prêts
accordé aux différents pays alors le
point sur lequel il faut peut-être bien
revenir c'est le fait que la commission
exige en réalité que les priorités
politiques qu'elle a fixés en
particulier la transition écologique que
ce qu'on appelle le fameux green deal
que ses priorités politiques soient
respectés et d'autre part il est clair
qu'elle veut avancer sur cette idée de
mutualisation des dettes alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que il
n'ya pas là de deux points de compromis
entre ce que proposait 4 frugaux est ce
que propose la commission que donc les
débats vont être houleux et qu'il faudra
de nombreuses réunions du conseil
européen pour pouvoir avancer sur cette
question si tenté que l'on avance un
méga voyez-vous tout de même avec tout
ce que l'on nous dit un compromis avec
ces quatre pays et 4 frigo bah si vous
voulez je pense qu'un compromis est
d'une certaine manière inévitable mais
il est très clair que on est en présence
une opposition forte de la part de ces
cas pays et il faut rappeler que s'il
n'ya pas l'unanimité ça ne peut pas
soufflé ses propositions ne peuvent pas
se concrétiser dans un port
qu'est ce que pourraient être les bases
un compromis très certainement de
renforcer le contrôle de la commission
sur le budget des pays qui prendrait de
l'argent qu'ils obtiendraient de
l'argent à travers les différents
mécanismes peut-être une réduction de
l'endettement général de la commission
bref on irait plutôt dans je dirais le
domaine d'un plus grand contrôle sur les
sommes qui seraient à ce moment là à
utiliser et ça c'est un point que
l'espagne et surtout l'italie semble
vouloir refuser absolument
donc voilà on est parti pour un débat et
une négociation qui sera extrêmement
difficile pour résumé jacques si on vous
lit bien
je n'ai pas optimiste et hélas non et je
dois dire que je voudrais est trop petit
mais si vous regardez une grosso modo
les sommes qui sont en cause avec le
plan franco allemand on est grosso modo
autour de 1000 milliards d'euros avec le
plan de la commission 12150 si on
regarde le plan de relance qui a été
déjà acté
aux etats unis ses 2300 milliards
or l'économie américaine elle est en
fait plus petit que l'économie de
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne donc déjà là il ya un
problème tout à fait évident et je passe
évidemment sur la question des
négociations qui seront comme je voulais
dit extrêmement difficile en fait la
solution qui aurait été la plus
rationnelle et certainement la plus
facile à mettre en oeuvre
c'était la solution qui consistait à
dire aux pays-bas écoutez vous faites
les plans dont vous avez besoin ne va
pas regarder ce que vous faites est
votre endettement et bien c'est
directement la banque centrale
européenne qui le reprend mais
malheureusement il y à l'arrêt du 5 mai
de la cour de cars seront qui est venu
d'une certaine manière faire capoter
je dirais tout cette belle mécanique et
c'est peut-être pour ça que l'on est
aujourd'hui rentré dans cette logique de
propositions qui devront être âprement
discutés dans plusieurs conseils
européens
merci jacques pour toutes ces
explications qui nous donne à réfléchir
merci à vous et à bientôt et à bientôt
sur rt france